fifty years ago Neil Armstrong and Buzz
Aldrin made history when they became the
first humans to walk on the moon surface
today companies and governments are
thinking about going back for a slightly
different reason they want to mine the
moon these organizations are working on
technologies that can use raw resources
from the lunar surface for everything
from life support to rocket fuel how
feasible is this and is it even legal my
name is on Hill abode Madrid I'm the
director of the center for space
resources the Colorado School of Mines
we spoke with on Hell Abood Madrid to
learn more so can you tell us a little
bit about lunar mining this is an idea
that's been around for a while what has
led to this resurgence of interest in
mining the moon the important thing to
understand about space resources is the
work space these are resources that are
in space and that we want to utilize in
space when we talk space resources is a
variety of things that we can use from
space some of them are concrete like
metals and oxygen and water but some of
them are intangible resources like solar
energy like microgravity ultra-high
vacuum you do not travel from Denver to
New York City and bring a big tank of
gas to get there and also to return you
refuel your vehicle as you go along and
you use the resources and you're in your
destination same thing in space that
idea has been around since the beginning
of the Space Age in the 1960s when the
NASA realized that if they were going to
have humans on the surface of the Moon
they would probably need some resources
there for example oxygen to breathe or
water to drink during the Apollo years
that was not necessary because they were
going to be there for just a few hours
and then come back but after that that
idea has stayed and now it's becoming
more real and and more important
especially if we're talking about
staying there for weeks and months at a
time
what a lot of people hear about lunar
mining the first thing that pops into
their head is why go all the way to the
moon when we have these resources on
earth do you think there's a strong
economic case or perhaps even a
political case to go to the moon to
extract these resources he's not
about bringing the resources to earth
it's about using the resources in space
for space applications why because one
of the most expensive things about space
exploration is transportation lifting up
ourselves from the from the ground it's
an extensive and energy intensive
operation if we could find the
propellant that we need in space so we
don't have to carry it from Earth that
would be the way to go you mentioned
several different resources that could
be found on the moon can you tell us a
little bit about what those resources
are 45% of the Moonies oxygen oxygen
that is tied to the rocks we can use it
for breathing or a set propellant their
regions on the pulse of the moon that
have never seen the light of the Sun
they have accumulated water from comets
and asteroids that have deposited the
eyes there and it can be utilized for
water for drinking purposes or growing
plans or relating to hydrogen and oxygen
which is the most energetic rocket
propellant known
there's metals all over the surface
could be iron could be titanium aluminum
magnesium all of those metals that we
use for construction and for making
parts it's also silicon silicon that
it's important for making solar cells
the other element that is important is
just the lunar soil itself this will be
good for construction for habitats could
be used for 3d printing if you want to
have tools spare parts so that's another
very important resource the moon
presents several challenges that aren't
found on earth it has a low gravity
environment very harsh radiation
extremely low temperatures and extremely
high temperatures so how our engineers
thinking about overcoming these
challenges most of them of the
operations at the beginning will be done
robotically we won't have humans on the
surface so we will have to have either
remotely control or fully autonomous
machines that will have to be small
because we are only limited to a certain
mass that we can get to the moon with a
reduced gravity level your traction goes
down a little bit in terms of power we
have solar power so we will have to
learn how to capture that or provide
other sources of energy such as nuclear
power and what is the status of these
robots right now is this something that
actually exists and is ready to fly next
year
is still mostly science fiction in just
like on earth it goes through a sequence
of operations first is the exploration
identification of the resource then
you're gonna extract process
manufacturing we're gonna go by the same
sequence that we follow on earth so
identifying the resources is expected to
happen in the next two to five years in
fact they already payloads that are
being planned for the next couple of
years that will carry to the moon some
instruments to identifying the resource
how much oxygen do we have how much
water it's on those firmly shadow
regions of the moon those will be
followed in the next five years and
Beyond by demonstrations of technology
now let's demonstrate that technology we
know where the resource is let's see how
much oxygen we can extract how we can
store it this will be done at a scale in
which at the same time that we
demonstrated a technology it can start
being used by humans that will be on the
surface of the Moon and it coincides
nicely with plans to have humans by 2024
and beyond large-scale operations when
once we start setting plans that will
collect oxygen and metals and water at
scales in which we will need it for a
large production of propellants and the
like that's more than the 10 to 15 years
but a lot it's needed to be done before
you do that several technologies have
been developed to a point of a prototype
some of those things can be ready to be
tested all the things will require
further technology development as we
learn more and more the state of the
resource and the technology that will be
needed to extract so it sounds like
there's going to have to be some
exploratory missions to find where these
resources are what are the best regions
to extract them from is this something
that you think is going to be undertaken
by governments first or do you think
corporations and private interests are
going to be leading the lunar Gold Rush
so to speak this is something that most
probably will be accomplished by
governments by space agencies that are
interested on these resources for
exploration and for sustaining humans
the private space sector can come in to
help on the technologies that will be
used to excavate it to extract them
companies on earth have plenty of
experience here and they can be utilized
by our space agency
to continue with extraction of elements
one of the major stumbling blocks to
actually bringing this into reality is
going to be policy and so I was curious
to know is mining the moon even legal
the outer space treaty that was signed
and ratified by more than a hundred
countries specifically is stated a
country cannot own any celestial body
but left Todd was the possibility to
extract the resources without owning the
planetary body two countries have
already taken a unilateral approach to
this first the United States in 2015
with a commercial space act it makes it
clear that any company that resides in
the United States can go ahead and
extract the resources that was followed
by Luxembourg in Europe the rest of the
world is also asking how is that
everybody can get involved so that
minimize conflicts so all of those
questions are now out there in terms of
the legal and they will have to be
settled before we also go out and
extract resources in a large scale we
may use them at the beginning if if
humans have to survive there for a few
weeks we may extract the oxygen we
actually beam there I mean United States
have been there without claiming
ownership of the moon and so the same
thing will happen at the beginning with
some resources that will be essential
for just survival but when we start
extracting it on a large scale we will
have to come up with a coherent legal
framework with mining on earth
environmental groups take it very
seriously
a lot of people say it two-face is the
earth and this is conceivably something
that could happen on the moon if these
operations get to become large-scale
it might to face the moon is this
something that organizations that are
pursuing resource extraction in space
are thinking about and how might we
minimize the effects on the lunar
environment the moon has been an object
of adoration for millennia for all
cultures we see very clearly the moon is
probably the only object that we see in
a large scale there's been already
concerns about the impact on historic
places like Apple 11 and how mining
operations are going to affect that so
there's
selphie an environmental component
that's not gonna be an issue I mean the
mining operations we're talking about to
sustain humans are many skill to
anything that we have on earth when we
talk about mining water from the lunar
poles we're gonna be extracting water
from a place that not only we cannot see
it has not seen the light of the Sun for
billions of years so you will never get
to see what happens in there and we're
talking at a very small operation to
conduct exploration that we want to do
in the you know several decades from now
at some point if this becomes large
enough that you have large operations
that will require a lot of excavation
and extraction there may be an effect by
then but that's something that will have
to be considered again just like the
legal aspects how much we want to have
this done or where should it happen so
that it doesn't cause race any any more
concerns on hell thank you so much for
joining us today and telling us more
about how we're going to mind the moon
it is a pleasure to be here Daniel to
share some of what is happening on
planets to extract resources from the
moon and beyond